This is it. This is the month where I
make a run at it. I am going to try to
make $30,000 in one month trading by
tripling my trading size. Once you can
consistently make money with a smaller
amount, all you need to do to make more
money is increase your size. So, that's
what I'm going to do this month. I'm
going to show you every trade I take,
walk [music] you through every part of
the process, good or bad. Keep you
updated on any changes I make, and how
adjusting to the new size increase
affects me and my trading.
>> Order filled.
>> And then I'm just going to have my
target somewhere up here at the open.
>> Yeah, at this point it doesn't look
great just because the ES is just kind
of continuing lower. I think if the ES
was going to bounce, it would have done
it right here. Now, riskreward-wise, I
think it's still just, you know, it was
a decent looking trade. 50/50 kind of
thing, and I think the 50/50 would have
been a great, you know, riskreward, but
knocked out. Looks like it's just going
to continue lower.
So, I lost over $5,000 this week, and
I've never lost that much money in
trading before in one week. It's because
I made a lot of dumb mistakes. I just
sized up and I've realized when you size
up the money is a lot more intense and
so you're way more likely to revert back
to some dumb mistakes you made on
Monday. I got in way too early. I didn't
wait for a really good spike and flush
lower kind of a final fake out that I
really find way more high probability
and I you know instead had some FOMO
thought oh what if I jump in right here
and or or I don't jump in here and I I
wait for a better setup and I miss out
on a trade and you know now I'm thinking
well that you know if I miss out on the
trade that's three or four or you know
$5,000 that's a big key I need to not
do. The second one is betting against
really strong momentum. As a reversal
trader, I'm always betting counter trend
in a way, but I always try and make sure
that the trend is clearly over and has
high chance to be done and looking to
reverse. But I've noticed over time is
that when there is a really strong
momentum move that it doesn't reverse
right away. A lot of the time it takes
time for that momentum to work itself
out. And so I know in those spots that
it's better to just not take a trade
there and know that it's less likely and
less probable. And instead I jumped in
and took the trade.
The third one was betting against the
big picture trend
>> cuz it looks like it has momentum
potential. Of course it could not, but
the risk of waiting too long is just it
it just goes without me. what is the
trend over the past couple days, past
couple weeks, and I took a trade in
gold. It had a nice move up into a
resistance level, but I thought going
into that day that the major trend was
to the upside and so it was more likely
that once it hits that resistance level,
it's just going to maybe slow down for a
minute, but it's going to continue
higher. And I tunnel visioned, looked
at, you know, the micro trend and
thought, well, it looks like, you know,
it's giving me some micro patterns and
signals that it could reverse. It
started to reverse but really did a fake
out to the downside and then shot higher
again because that big picture trend
came back into play once it had a
pullback. And so those are three big
lessons I need to use going into this
week. I'm going to make a a piece of
paper on my desk so I can tangibly focus
on the key major mistakes I think I
commonly make now, especially when the
size is bigger. And so hopefully I can
avoid those dumb mistakes and make some
money going into this next week.
>> But I like the potential to go lower.
>> Just gonna enter in and and um then I
can explain it in a second more.
>> Um so big picture,
the market is bullish and so it's had
this massive move up. Um but it's also
hitting this trend line. Um, and I I
want to see I kind of need to see how it
reacts to this previous high.
Part of me feels like I'm going against
my rules a little bit of really strong
uptrend. Just trying to look at this.
See if I want to move my stop down. I
don't think yet. I think I want to move
my stop down if it starts to punch down
to here. just because of my lack of
confidence in the trade, my upsetness
with myself or frustration of myself of
kind of I don't know, feeling like I
broke my rules a little.
Okay. Well, small loss on that.
Okay. So after
breaking my rules for a couple days, I
have wrote down on a sheet kind of what
directions I think and trades I want for
each market. I'm going to get long.
I'm a little nervous. ES is hitting
highs,
but I'm going to get long here. Big
picture is aligned. There is a nice
bottoming pattern with a flush here.
Downtrend into this area isn't crazy.
>> Order filled. you know, initial target
will definitely be the open and we'll
just kind of see how
things get going here.
Really gross.
I'm going to go long on this. The idea
that it's basically faked lower
and it's going to continue and break
this and continue higher with the trend.
And this is just a pullback
in instead of looking for a reversal
here.
Order filled.
I'm going move my target up a bit more
because I don't want to get knocked out
on a spike, which just the idea that
this market is very volatile. It has the
potential.
Order filled.
big picture on a fivem minute. I think
it looks really good potential wise, but
I'm also nervous that it's just doing a
little
retracement here
30% of this move and then failing.
Just going to move to five minute for
now because it's just choppy and I mean
it's either going to knock me out or it
doesn't, right? Yeah. I'm trying to in
some spots since the market's been so
trendy is looking for some of these
reversals to fail where, you know, it
has a strong uptrend. It hits a level,
does a pullback and starts to make some
nice price action to go higher to
continue that uptrend. This one, I don't
know. I think I force this one a little
bit. I think in better spots, the better
signal is when it hits this level and
starts to chop a little bit versus this
was chopping too long. And so it might
just go into a chop fest.
Pretty gross.
So, I'm down over 11K in the last two
weeks, and I've never been down that
much money before, and it it feels
emotional, and I, you know, feel like a
failure, and I've kind of lost
confidence in my ability to execute my
trading strategy. It's not the strategy
that's losing me money. It's the fact
that every day I'm going in focusing on
the money and not focusing on the
process and not focusing on being
patient of wanting to take a trade. Uh
that aligns up with my strategy versus,
[music] you know, oh, you know, oh,
there's a potential trade here and
jumping in on it and I'm not getting in
when I need to be, right? And so I'm
trading very uh emotionally and all over
the place. And so what I'm trying to do
now is reenter myself because
the market is always going to be there
and I don't need to take trades every
day to be successful especially at the
size now. That's what has really kind of
u made me go a little crazy I think is
that the size is so big now that I can
take one trade and make you know 5k from
it or if I um size up a little it could
be like 10k and that's uh kind of
mind-blowing. And so [music] dealing
with that has made me need to realize I
need to, you know, focus on the process
and [music] go into every day not caring
about uh if I take a trade that day and
if I make money or not. The focus needs
to be on uh a good successful trading
day needs to be [music] if I go in and
take a trade that is based on my
strategy, not if I go in and make money
or lose money. And so that's what I want
to do going into this next week and
going into the next couple weeks. I
don't want to frame it as uh even for
this video, oh it's a success if I can
dig myself out of this hole. That that
could take longer. Um you know, doesn't
depending on what happens with my
trading and the market, right? And so I
want to a win needs to be if I go in and
take trades that I want and take trades
that I like versus jumping in on trades
and making money. Um because that's
again going to keep me in that emotional
driven state of FOMOing, [music] of
being nervous, being scared, and tunnel
visioning and and just continuing to
lose money. With that being said,
hopefully the comeback starts now and I
can focus up this week and just take a
couple of trades when they come along
and focus on being patient because
that's what's going to make [music] me
money in the long run.
Okay, let's get this train rolling. It
is [sighs] a fresh week. I am going into
this week with the idea of I'm trying to
just execute my strategy how I see fit
and be super patient. Um, a win is, you
know, uh, getting my trade and strategy
when it shows up versus trying to take
trades and make money in the market. The
ES and the NASDAQ are not aligned, which
doesn't look good for trading either of
them. Usually I like to have them kind
of be move in the same direction because
it's more likely that they do something.
Took a quick break, but
uh you know ES is just choppy. NASDAQ
had a little spike at the open, but it's
still just choppy. I'm just going to
call it a day. Totally happy with that.
No need to push it when there's really
nothing going on.
It's made a nice higher low.
off of this area I've looked for. It's a
double bottom head and shoulders. I
mean, off of this previous high here,
nice bounce there and then a bounce
here. So, that's pretty dang good
structure. The only thing is I feel like
my intuition is kind of saying that this
is um it's already had two big moves for
the day.
>> Order filled.
And I'm just nervous about this gold
trade just because it is a little later
than I normally take a trade and it
feels like uh could just be getting
choppy. But also I'm just nervous
because I'm scared about the outcome.
You know what if it list loses here
but you know again the reasons to get in
were solid and that's that's what I want
to be focusing on, right? It's not about
the trade outcome. It's about the
process of executing when it's follows
your strategy and pushing through that
nervousness and emotion.
That could be a a break of this trend.
Now, I need to see a couple candlesticks
and see what it does. But I think at
this point, I'll move my stop loss up to
here at least. I would really be kind of
upset to get out here.
You know, getting out here still, I was
happy with how I traded. I think I
stayed in it. you know, getting it out
somewhere up here would have just been,
I think, kind of, I don't know, more
emotional and just because the trend was
still in play. There was no reason to
get out based on the charts until now.
Um, so still a nice trade. Nice to get a
something in the books, but bummer that,
you know, to get knocked out here cuz
part of me is like, oh, it looks like it
could just knock out and then reverse.
But, you know, that's that's the signal
I'm going with. And I'm going to call it
a day on that.
Gold is potentially getting that
pullback I'd like. I actually think I
would get long here on this as it's come
up and it's it's done a 50% pullback.
It's gone past that actually. And if it
pulls back and breaks higher, I think
that's a good It's just a really good
sweep lower. It's kind of nerve-wracking
getting in on this volatility
a little bit, but
I like it to the long side.
>> Okay. Definitely some whips here on
gold. That's kind of spooky, but held
through the pullback I want. And you
know that's that's what I'm looking for.
>> Dang. So I had a break even or not a
break even loss on that. I really
thought that pullback was going to look
good. Seven contracts. Holy I
almost accidentally did seven.
>> That would have been not a good time. I
like this on a fivem minute. Just using
a one minute as an entry signal. And a
fivem minute looks really good.
But again, I'm not going to touch it.
I don't want to get out just because I'm
scared. You know, the big picture is a
nice signal. We could pull up a little
bit more, make a new high on the ES, and
then and then start sell off.
Okay, out on that trade.
So, this is the end of week three and I
am still really in the hole. But going
through this process, I've realized and
you know kind of after week two when I
was in that emotional spiral is and this
week I feel like I've I've started to
write the ship. Maybe not in results
yet, but I started to refocus on
the important parts of trading. And this
week I've done a lot better job of
refocusing and saying, you know, taking
stuff away and saying, "Okay, it doesn't
matter about the results. I have to
focus on the process, taking away
trading gold and oil and saying, "Okay,
I know I can be good at focusing on just
those morning reversals and just trading
those and being patient and not forcing
trades, not FOMO, not feeling like I
have to make this money back because I
am in such a hole and so next week I
have to go into the week, focus on the
process because that's what actually
makes money trading and [music] be
disciplined in my execution because
right now having an 8% win rate is
really not reflective of I think my
strategy and my ability. It's me being
in this emotional death spiral. You
know, it's a part of trading of of
adjusting and putting all this pressure
on myself, but I have to adjust quickly
because otherwise I'm going to lose a
lot of money and I'll come out of it on
the other side hopefully being a better
trader and being able to make more
money.
And so I, you know, don't really know if
I'll take much of a trade today. I don't
plan on trading very long cuz I, you
know, had my 50k ultramarathon over the
weekend. I am completely exhausted.
>> Let's go.
>> Trading a long time today is not going
to be a smart thing because I won't make
good decisions. Um, I'm sitting in my
chair right now. I pretty much always
stand when I'm trading. Standing on my
legs right now just doesn't work very
well. So, I wanted to show up to the
markets today and kind of see what was
going on, take a a trade if it sets up
really perfectly. But, you know, if it
if it's kind of in that middle ground,
uh, where we are right now, you know,
where it's like uh middle of the range,
not a high probability to high
probability level, um, there's just no
point in in forcing things.
There's no really strong read and so I'm
just going to call it. Um there's no
reason to try and force anything.
I think that's a good enough signal
there for me. And again with the NASDAQ
having the ability to really spike
higher here. I'm going to jump in.
Nice confirmation on the ES so far.
Still hasn't confirmed it's broken that.
But I'm just going to let this play out.
I like the entry. It's following my
timing, my strategy, you know, head and
shoulders here. And I was waiting till
both kind of aligned.
Just nervous, especially with
this still, I don't know, kind of
selling off here at this downtrend.
Ideally, I should really have my stop
below here.
Knocks me out there. But I mean, I
figured that, hey, it's either going to
go up or it's going to fail here.
I think I made some good discipline
moves this week um in terms of jumping
off when I wasn't, you know, sure and
essentially just getting more aligned
with how I should be trading my
strategy. And that's the whole goal of
trading for me going through adjusting
to this big size. Now, you know, I
haven't really got a win yet, which is
really frustrating and rough. Um, which,
you know, causes um me to feel like I'm
going to fall back into that emotional
spiral.
But trying to limit that and and stay on
the right side of things and being
patient and knowing that it will come
and that I don't need to adjust my
strategy that the market's you know been
tricky right now in terms of making huge
moves and that triggering FOMO. I mean
it was a tough trading week and I only
took one loss. So that's a huge
improvement on what was happening
before. I'm gonna trade next week and
hopefully come into next week and you
know at the end of the day like I am two
wins away from being break even. That's
what I have to remember. I don't need
that many trades to make a lot of money
with this strategy.
Okay, coming into today, I've taken a
few days off from trading. And so, it
helps me to get back into the swing of
things by visualizing what I want to do,
reminding myself how my strategy works
and what I'm looking for. You know, what
is that repeatable thing that I'm
looking for every day versus just kind
of showing up and being like, okay, I'm
just going to trade. Uh, market hasn't
opened yet. Got 7:30. my time is when it
opens and then other couple windows I
like 7:45 and 8. These are my two spots
where I want to see it come down in
reverse if [music] it's, you know,
either way at those timings. That's kind
of lines up with what is repeatable for
me versus I find, you know, going into
the market and just trying to enter in
randomly just does not work very well.
So, what I would like for a long here
now that it's broken the lows, I would
want a head and shoulders to go long
here because otherwise if it's way more
likely that we just especially for the
NASDAQ here is come up here, test this,
and just continue lower because we're
not really bouncing off of a a support
level. Now, we we could just be doing a
failed breakout at the overnight lows
here, but big picture, we could just be
in a downtrend. Um, that's going to
continue lower. You know,
I like this to the upside.
I really want to see. I'm nervous that
I'm just going to
>> order filled. It's just going to pump me
in and then rip lower. But I think I'm
just going to get in long
um through that nervousness because it
it's made a nice head and shoulders
there. I'm going to just put my stop
down here.
Spiking all the way back up here. I'm
going to go to break even. I want to
just see where we're at here. But a lot
of the times recently, I feel like it's
hit the open and then
slowed down. And so getting out at just
2x has been really good to do. I'll see
how we hit 2x, I think. And then I think
maybe I'll go previous candlestick with
the trailing stop. And while we wait for
this trade, make sure to check out the
Ninja Trader Arena Cup $400,000 real
money prize pool tournament. Half the
spots are already taken. So make sure to
get your spot here in this QR code or
the link below. I still might get out at
3x if it would pump up there just
because mentally that's just a big win
that I haven't had in a while. If this
also reverses here, I'll probably move
my stop up here as well.
I definitely if this starts popping up
here, I'm going to move trailing stop
like really tight here now
like up to 2x.
NASDAQ is popping as well for me
mentally. I feel like getting 5K on the
trade is kind of a mental number I
really want right now. It's not good,
but that's just the reality. But I also
don't want to just let that control what
I'm doing. I want to run a trailing stop
here if this is just going to continue
to pop. I don't think that's over greed.
I I'm just going to put a trailing stop
here right at the bottom of this candle
because I think either it's going to
keep going up or it's going to knock me
out. And if it knocks me out here at
4,700,
I'm totally happy with that.
Come on, hold, hold, and keep going.
That's okay. I'm totally happy with
that. But six start to the day, six
start to the week. That is exactly what
I want to be doing in the mornings. And
that's my repeatable setup right there.
You know, get the emotions of managing
it and dealing with this. If I wasn't as
triggered by the money right now, I
would have held through this and let it
do a 50% pullback and let it go higher.
But all things considered, I waited for
that setup. This is exactly what I
wanted and that's what I want to be
doing with my trading. That's what's
repeatable and that's how I will be
consistently profitable.
So, we're coming down to [sighs] the
support zone on the NASDAQ. We've had a
nice pullback and we're coming into this
15-minute reversal timing. So, normally
I'd be looking for, you know, potential
long here. Uh the problem is if we look
at the ES, it's just chopping here. It's
just opened up and really done nothing.
And I have been trying to drill into my
head.
If they're not aligned, I don't take a
trade.
Okay, so NASDAQ and ES are just sitting
here chopping. We just opened and
chopped. It didn't really do what I was
looking for. We're coming up on 8:00,
you know, the 30-minute window. The
15-minute window right here didn't
really make sense. It just kind of
sitting here chopping. Uh, you know, and
again, I I want to be going into every
day looking for the 15 or 30 minute
reversal. And if it doesn't show up,
just call it. just move on. Don't get
sucked in of trying to capture a win
today. If it doesn't show up, it doesn't
show up. There's no point in trying to
stay and figure this out because it
could just chop here forever. I I'm sure
it eventually goes some direction, but
is that tradable? And is that
consistently tradable for me to repeat
over and over? And in my experience, for
me, no. And so, I'm just going to call
it and move on to the next day.
The last five weeks have been a roller
coaster for me. I think now the last
like two weeks have been way more
focused and exactly how I want to trade
and how I know how to be profitable
trading. And the first two weeks, if you
look at, you know, kind of just go back
in the video and look at how emotional I
was, how focused on the results I was,
and how I was kind of in just like this
emotional death spiral. When you look at
my my results was destroying my trading.
And I think that's exactly what happens
to every trader when they get way too
focused on the results or the money gets
too big and and you just get in that
tunnel vision. I really had that for the
first two weeks and having to reset
myself and, you know, [music] find a a a
bottom and essentially rewrite the ship.
Um, so I didn't, you know, start to burn
tens of thousands of dollars now at my
new size and doing that while trying to,
you know, film it all and everything was
it it made it very it added to the
intensity. And so, um, you know, that's
something I wasn't used to. And
adjusting to that took a couple weeks.
And [music] um now going forwards, you
know, over the these last two weeks, you
can I I can really see looking back is
my focus has got to the right mindset
and the right way I want to be thinking
about trading and the right way any
successful trader should think about
trading because at the end of the day,
you know, it's about doing what I
personally [music]
can consistently and profitably do
[music] and repeat every single day, you
What I was trying to do in the first two
weeks was
jump in and, you know, try and just read
the market in real time and capture
every move that the day has, even if
it's in my morning window. Um, and I
can't consistently do that at the end of
the day. Um, and it makes it too intense
for me. So now shifting back and
regaining that focus of, you know, I
actually know what I can be consistent
with. And it's just waiting for that 15
minute and that 30 minute reversal
timing and waiting for the markets to be
aligned together. And if I'm really
confident in my read, then I take a
trade. But if it's kind of back and
forth, just close out. There's no reason
to force a trade. I have the luxury of
being patient and just saying, "Hey, I'm
just going to move on with the day."
Even if, you know, I stayed another 10
minutes and maybe I caught a trade, it's
just not worth it. Just wait for, you
know, I could take four trades a month
and if I make, you know, four or five
from [music] just those four trades
being wins, that's 20K a month. Next
time I size up, it gets bigger and
bigger. So, that's what I want to focus
on going forwards in my trading because
that is how I'm going to be consistently
profitable trading with this new size
over time.